where you may be tempted to shop on a
whim don't do that a new study finds
nearly 90% of Americans make impulse
purchases and men spend more on them
than women Charisse Jones is USA's
today's national business correspondent
she's here to explain why we impulse buy
and how to break what can be a really
really bad habit good morning to you
Charisse Jones Lauren I know sales and
buffets are my witness too and you say
people should always ask do I want it do
I need it yeah you know you should give
yourself a little break you can wait
like 24 to 48 hours and say do I really
think those sneakers are that cute or do
I need to like save my money you know
bring cash and leave your credit cards
and your Apple watch at home because
that way and limits how much you can
spend and if you can just use your
credit card the expenses like pushed off
for a few weeks but when you're putting
out those $20 bills or their singles you
realize you're spending all of that
money are very conscious of what you're
spending really interesting to hear that
men actually impulse buy more than women
yeah I know what are the techniques and
stores are using to get us to shell out
on willingly or unwantedly well you know
they give you an offer you can't refuse
right they say that it's 50% off or
two-for-one so you feel you'd be foolish
to pass it up right and then they also
make a mood or an experience right they
play that music and you feel really good
and kind of relaxed your defenses come
down and they also create this kind of
maze to get to the cash register right
so you're passing all these goodies like
the lipgloss and the candy and the
magazine so you fill your basket up and
when you get up there you know you're
out of all your money so is there such
thing as smart impulse buying I don't
know if they're smart impulse buying I
think that you have to treat yourself
sometimes right you have a stressful day
you want to get something extra it's a
good idea to have a little fun money
that you can tap into but make sure you
pay your other bills first so it's fine
to do with sometimes you just have to be
smart about it I thought it was
interesting to back to what Tony's
saying between men and women because is
acts as having 75% off and I really I
was there yesterday lost my friggin mind
right what is the difference between how
men shop and how women shop when it
comes to impulse buying I think that
women are more practical and they're
more frugally than when they split are
they
more questions yeah right but more
practical you know men might buy you
know bigger ticket items like they might
want to get electronics women are going
for a pair of shoes or a mascara or a
lip gloss so there's a lot of
stereotypes that say we spend a lot more
but we actually when we splurge we're
thinking about that family budget
I find myself splurging at places like
bright aid i buyed like white it's like
how did I just spend $80 I don't think
my mama police need like snacking while
shopping think every time I go in to
ride it I got to open up something right
away I got a seltzer water walking
through it's five dollars it's a stuff
at the counter too when you're checking
out magazines alright Cherise Jones
thank you thank you
well Cherise Jones again thank you for
all your help